[Music]
when you're on the trail that long you
don't really think about how long is it
gonna take me to get to somewhere or how
fast am I going you're thinking about
don't get yourself hurt
my name is Karl Meltzer and I am an
ultra-marathoner we did 36 miles
it was pretty weekday but no one's ever
been this far in ten days I just
recently broke the Appalachian Trail
record from Maine to Georgia at 2000 189
miles and I completed that in 45 days 22
hours and 38 minutes beating the
previous record by just a little under
10 hours total mileage average per day
for that 46 days will be forty seven
point six the 80 is not a walk in the
park it's a hard trail and every time I
clip my foot and it goes forward it
totally stresses my swimming me you
really have to have a team it's not just
the one guy running it's really the crew
who if they're not perfect for you then
it really won't be successful I think
Appalachian Trail not only is it very
popular and iconic but it's also very
difficult now it's all downhill and easy
I am concentrating on my foot placement
all the time so two hours goes by like
nothing just because I'm zoned I'm
sewing out I slammed my head into the
ground a number of times and it beats
you down you have to expect that but you
can beat it too as long as you just keep
persevering and fighting through the
issues that you're going to have the
last day I ran 85 miles my body was so
amped and ready to be done that it
didn't matter really how far it was I
felt the same in my lady as I did a mile
10 might just numb at that point really
strong opponent it's important for
people to know the 80 is a special place
and it should be protected it's a trail
for one who wants to gain fellowship
with nature no matter whether you're
running it whether you're walking it
whether you're taking 10 years to do it
when you walk that trail you have a vibe
and you feel it
every year someone else's gets a little
bit faster someone will break my record
for sure it might come this year I don't
know I'm still going to be happy because
I gave it everything I had you know I
think that's what's important this is
the southern Appalachian salamander it
breathes entirely through its skin which
makes it incredibly sensitive to water
quality and temperature and with average
temperatures increasing yearly their
future has become quite murky the
Appalachian region is home to more
salamander species than anywhere else in
the world
adults top out at 7 inches and females
are slightly larger than males they are
found across the Carolinas Georgia and
Tennessee they live in wet forested
areas as they need to stay moist to
respirate properly unfortunately these
areas have been shrinking and warming up
quickly climate change and habitat loss
are grave concerns for this remarkable
species this is the southern Appalachian
salamander
[Music]
I think glass is crazy but in a very
good way I think he's very smart I think
he knows what he's doing
people think he's a sadist or whatever
it's like my trail film a flair for the
dramatic I think a sassy man Laz
Kentrell a true backwoods rebel of
Tennessee created one of the world's
most grueling foot races one that is so
challenging it leads many to assume it
must be an act of sadism are you isatis
no no I think people are obsessed with
comfort to the point that they forget if
you don't have any discomfort in your
life how do you know when you feel good
the Berkeley marathons is a 100-mile
race comprised of five 20-mile loops
which you have 60 hours to complete it's
over some pretty rugged terrain it's got
a massive amount of climb about 66,000
feet you have just your map and compass
it's cold it's wet it's miserable you're
alone the fact that they'll probably
almost certainly fail makes it more
appealing this started in 85 and we've
had 14 finishers yeah we always use a
camel because that's about the best
cigarette I think
[Music]
the course is located in frozen head
State Park home to the Brushy Mountain
State Penitentiary a location not chosen
by chance in 1977 James Earl Ray the man
who killed Martin Luther King jr. made
headlines again when he escaped the
prison in the 54 hours he was free he
only made it eight miles from his cell
because this terrain is no joke Don
Dyson man you could put together a race
course that would really challenge
people's soul I think every runner would
like to do better than James Earl Ray
and get further than eight miles
although some of them don't everybody
gets a big number for each loop
there's paperback books which are kind
of strategically placed so that to get
them all you have to follow the course
and you pull out the page number that
matches your bid you have to turn your
pages to show that you've done the
course he has a brilliant sense of humor
he's parodying the sport of
ultramarathon running those of us who
run ultras we have a certain egoism that
we think we're pretty good because of
what we can do and so he set out to
puncture that balloon Laz keeps making
it harder because he's trying to put it
at the limit of human possibility
[Music]
after they decided that they've had
enough and quit we play caps on the
bugle both because taps is what you play
for someone who's died in action and
because they they're being tapped out
I think genuinely in his heart he wants
to see people succeed
when people actually finish five loops
and you see him at the end he's so
excited an ef-1 or more of them comes in
it's an inspiring thing it's hard to
believe that human can accomplish that
it's good that some years no one
finishes because the bark we should win
sometimes too you reach the cause from
home show would you like to leave a
shout-out tonight deep in the heart of
the Appalachian Mountains an unlikely
ally is helping families to connect with
their loved ones serving time in nearby
maximum-security prisons
[Music]
I'm Elizabeth Sanders the general
manager of WM MT which is the community
radio station of Apple Shaw based in
Whitesburg Kentucky over the past 20
years the prison industry in Appalachia
has grown exponentially
now housing thousands of prisoners from
all over the United States for many
living behind bars the show calls from
home is their primary means of outside
communication I just called you say I
love you doing good all their calls from
home is a way for folks to call in and
leave shoutouts for their loved ones who
are locked up in prisons around here
Prison phone rates are really exorbitant
or if you're on lockdown you don't get
to use it at all another thing that
makes it really hard or that the folks
that are incarcerated here their
families are really really far away so
this is a way that they can keep in
touch every week all different sorts of
folks call in it's everything from
friends to mothers to children
for Michelle Hudson whose partner
William is serving a life sentence calls
from home helps keep them connected
I've been calling into the show every
Monday since 2012 calls from home helps
him to just regain some strength regain
his focus and even put a smile on his
face it has become his eyes to help him
see outside of those walls hearing those
shows every single week helps them hold
on helps them to just get through
another day I think it's easy to forget
that these folks who are in the prison
system around here are actually part of
our community so to not forget them or
their family members that are far away
is really important that show brings
that humanity back it brings the
compassion and love that they're missing
on a daily basis back to their cell
I just let's just going out to my
handsome King out Wallens Ridge hey
c-walk what's going on big grip it's
your love Michelle I missed you